"Unos 115 miligramos de oxicodona", respondí,
"quizá más".
Lo había dicho tantas veces a tantos médicos,
que respondí con indiferencia.
Pero era distinto esta vez.
Mi médico se puso serio,
me miró y dijo:
"Travis, esa dosis de opioides es demasiada alta.
Es hora de que empieces a dejar la medicación".
En dos meses de recetas cada vez más frecuentes
era la primera vez que alguien se preocupaba.
De hecho, era la primera vez que hablaba con alguien
de mi terapia con opioides.
Nunca me habían advertido,
ni aconsejado,
ni me habían propuesto un plan...
solo me habían dado montones de recetas.
Lo que ocurrió luego marcó mi experiencia traumática.
Me dieron lo que hoy califico como un agresivo régimen de suspensión
que consistía en dividir la medicación en cuatro dosis,
y reducir cada una por semana durante un mes.
Como resultado, terminé en una crisis aguda por abstinencia de opioides.
La consecuencia, por decirlo de otro modo,
fue el infierno.
Los primeros síntomas de abstinencia
[SEMANA 1] se parecen a los de una gripe grave.
Estaba nauseabundo,
perdí el apetito,
me dolía todo el cuerpo
y el dolor del pie casi destrozado era cada vez más intenso.
Empecé con problemas para dormir por una sensación de sobreexcitación.
En ese momento,
pensé que no podía ser peor.
Y es porque no sabía lo que vendría.
[SEMANA 2]
Al comienzo de la segunda semana,
mi vida fue mucho peor.
A medida que los síntomas se hacían más virulentos,
mi termostato interno se descontroló.
Transpiraba profusamente y de manera casi constante
y, si llegaba a salir al calor intenso de agosto,
el cuerpo se me cubría de piel de gallina.
La excitación que me impedía conciliar el sueño la primera semana
se transformó ahora en lo que llamaría la típica sensación de abstinencia.
Era un estado de nerviosismo intenso que me producía espasmos,
y no me permitía conciliar el sueño.
Pero quizá el síntoma más preocupante era el llanto.
Me brotaban lágrimas
sin motivo aparente
y sin previo aviso.
En aquel momento, parecía un trastorno nervioso,
como la piel de gallina.
Sadiye se preocupó y llamó al médico,
quien amablemente recomendó ingerir líquidos para contrarrestar las náuseas.
Para presionarlo, Sadiye le dijo: "Doctor, él no está nada bien",
y el médico respondió:
"Si está tan mal, puede retomar la dosis anterior por un tiempo".
"¿Y después qué?", pregunté.
"Vuelva a intentarlo más adelante", me dijo.
Pero de ninguna manera volvería a mi dosis anterior
a menos que tuviera un mejor plan
para superar la abstinencia la vez siguiente.
Así que asumimos el riesgo, y reduje otra dosis.
[SEMANA 3]
Al comienzo de la tercera semana,
mi mundo se oscureció.
Básicamente, dejé de comer
y casi no dormía por el estado de nervios
que me producía espasmos durante la noche.
Pero lo peor
era la depresión.
Las lágrimas que antes brotaban sin motivo aparente
ahora tenían un significado.
Varias veces al día sentía esa angustia en el pecho,
el anuncio de un llanto
que no podía detener,
y con ese llanto sobrevenía la desesperación y la desesperanza.
Empecé a pensar que nunca me recuperaría
ni del accidente ni de la abstinencia.
Sadiye llamó al médico
que nos recomendó contactar al equipo de tratamiento para el dolor
del médico que me atendió en la última hospitalización.
Nos pareció una excelente idea y lo hicimos de inmediato,
pero nadie nos ayudó.
La recepcionista al teléfono nos informó
que el equipo de tratamiento del dolor trabaja con pacientes internados
y que aunque recetan opioides para controlar el dolor
no siguen al paciente en las etapas de desintoxicación y abstinencia.
Enojados, volvimos a llamar al médico y le suplicamos que nos diera algo,
lo que fuera para ayudarme.
Pero todo lo que hizo fue disculparse,
porque mi caso estaba fuera de su alcance.
"Mi primer consejo", nos dijo, "decididamente no fue el mejor,
así que la recomendación oficial es que Travis retome la medicación
hasta que encuentre a alguien más competente para ayudarlo".
Por supuesto que quería volver a la medicación.
Estaba sufriendo.
Pero pensé que si lograba salir de la abstinencia a base de drogas,
nunca me liberaría de ellas,
así que decidimos arriesgarnos
y reduje la última dosis.
[SEMANA 4]
A medida que mi cerebro vivía la experiencia de una vida sin opioides
por primera vez en meses,
pensé que moriría.
Lo di por sentado.
(Solloza)
Perdón.
Porque si los síntomas no me mataban enseguida,
yo mismo me mataría.
Sé que suena dramático
porque para mí estar aquí años después,
sano y salvo,
es dramático.
Pero estaba profundamente convencido
porque había perdido la esperanza
de volver a una vida normal.
El insomnio se hizo insoportable
y luego de estar casi dos días sin dormir,
pasé una noche entera tendido en el baño del sótano.
O bien tenía la cabeza contra el piso para enfriarla con las baldosas,
o intentaba vomitar violentamente
a pesar de llevar días con el estómago vacío.
Cuando Sadiye me encontró así a altas horas de la noche
se horrorizó,
y volvimos a recurrir al teléfono.
Llamamos a todo el mundo.
A los cirujanos, a los médicos, a especialistas en dolor,
a cualquiera en internet,
y ninguno pudo ayudarnos.
Los pocos que nos atendieron al teléfono
nos aconsejaron retomar la medicación.
Una clínica independiente para el manejo del dolor
nos dijo que ellos recetaban opioides
pero que no hacían el seguimiento en la reducción de dosis y abstinencia.
Cuando la desesperación ya empezaba a notarse en mi voz,
como ahora,
la recepcionista respiró hondo y dijo:
"Sr. Rieder, quizá lo que Ud. necesite sea un lugar de rehabilitación
o una clínica de metadona".
No sabía qué hacer, así que seguí su consejo.
Colgué y empecé a llamar a esos sitios,
pero no tardé en descubrir que muchos de esos lugares
son para los que buscan recuperarse
del trastorno por el consumo prolongado de sustancias.
En el caso de los opioides,
el tratamiento no contempla precisamente retirarle la medicación al paciente
sino ir llevándolo hacia el consumo de opioides más seguros
y de acción más prolongada:
la metadona o buprenorfina como terapias de mantenimiento.
Además de esto, la lista de espera en estos sitios era sumamente larga.
Claramente, no era el tipo de paciente que trataban.
Luego de ser rechazado de una clínica de rehabilitación,
finalmente me di por vencido.
Estaba destruido y derrotado
y ya no podía más.
Le dije entonces a Sadiye que volvería a la medicación,
que empezaría con la dosis más baja posible
y que tomaría solo lo estrictamente necesario
para escapar a los efectos más virulentos de la abstinencia.
Esa noche, Sadiye me ayudó a subir las escaleras,
y por primera vez en semanas fui a la cama.
Tomé el frasco anaranjado que me recetaron,
lo dejé en la mesita...
y no la toqué.
Me dormí,
dormí toda la noche
y cuando me desperté,
los síntomas más graves habían disminuido notablemente.
Lo había logrado.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Esa también fue mi reacción.
(Risas)
Entonces...
Perdón, tengo que recomponerme un poco.
Creo que mi historia es importante,
pero no porque me considere especial.
Es importante precisamente porque no soy especial;
porque lo que me pasó no fue excepcional.
Mi dependencia de los opioides era totalmente predecible,
en función de la cantidad que me recetaron
y de la duración del tratamiento.
La dependencia no es más que la reacción normal del cerebro
a la ingesta excesiva de opioides
y, por eso, se daban todas las condiciones para que, desde un principio,
me hubiesen dado un régimen supervisado y bien pensado,
pero, aparentemente, nuestro sistema de salud no ha decidido
quién es responsable de pacientes como yo.
Los médicos me consideraron un paciente complejo
que necesitaba cuidados especiales,
quizá a cargo de médicos especialistas en dolor.
Estos médicos intentaron controlar el dolor,
pero cuando no pude dejar la medicación
pensaron que debía ser tratado por un especialista en adicciones.
Pero la medicina de adicciones está sobredemandada
y se dedica a los trastornos por el consumo prolongado de sustancias.
En definitiva, me recetaron una droga que requería un seguimiento a largo plazo
y no me lo dieron,
y ni siquiera estaba claro quién debía encargarse de esa supervisión.
Es la receta para un desastre
que amerita ser hablado y tratado
quizá en una charla TED,
pero el fracaso de los tratamientos para abandonar los opioides
es hoy un problema preocupante en EE. UU.
porque estamos en medio de una epidemia
en la cual 30 000 personas murieron de sobredosis en el año 2015.
Casi la mitad de esas personas consumieron opioides recetados.
La comunidad médica ha comenzado a reaccionar ante esta crisis,
pero, en gran parte, se ha limitado a recetar menos pastillas
y eso es, sin duda, de vital importancia.
Por ejemplo, hay cada vez más evidencia
de que los médicos en EE. UU. suelen recetar fármacos
aun cuando no es necesario,
en el caso de los opioides.
E incluso cuando son necesarios,
recetan mucho más de lo debido.
Estas consideraciones ayudan a entender por qué EE. UU.,
a pesar de tener tan solo el 5 % de la población mundial,
consume casi el 70 % del total de opioides recetados en el mundo.
Pero centrarse tan solo en la cantidad de medicamentos recetados
nos puede desviar de dos temas cruciales.
El primero es que los opioides son y seguirán siendo
terapias importantes para tratar el dolor.
Fui alguien que padeció de dolores agudos, reales y prolongados,
y les aseguro que estas drogas pueden hacer que la vida valga la pena.
Y segundo:
aún podemos combatir la epidemia
sin dejar de recetar opioides de forma responsable
a quienes realmente los necesitan,
siempre y cuando los médicos sepan administrar las pastillas que recetan.
Por ejemplo,
volvamos al régimen que me dieron para reducir los opioides.
¿Es razonable esperar
que un médico que receta opioides sepa que son demasiado agresivos?
Luego de que mi caso fuera publicado en una revista científica,
alguien del CDC me envió su guía de bolsillo para dejar los opioides.
Es un documento de cuatro páginas, en su mayoría con imágenes.
Allí enseñan a los médicos cómo reducir los opioides en los casos más fáciles
y una de las recomendaciones
es que la dosis inicial nunca debe reducirse más del 10 % por semana.
Si mi médico me hubiese dado ese plan,
mi tratamiento habría durado varios meses en lugar de semanas.
Seguramente no habría sido fácil.
Quizá habría sido molesto,
pero no habría sido un infierno.
Y esa debería ser la información
que quien receta un fármaco debería manejar.
Para terminar,
quiero decir que un manejo adecuado de los opioides por parte de los médicos
no es suficiente para resolver la crisis.
La epidemia que hay en EE. UU. va mucho más lejos,
pero cuando la medicación es responsable de decenas de miles de muertes al año,
un mal manejo de esas drogas es injustificable.
Ayudar a los pacientes con terapias para dejar los opioides
recetadas por el médico
puede no ser la solución final para esta epidemia,
pero sin duda sería un gran progreso.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)